kurze anmerkung bevor das video losgeht
ich hatte irgendwie so der dumme idee
mich mal wieder als lucy und ludger zu
verkleiden und einfach irgendein dumme
schauspiel zu machen also gleich gefällt
soll ich vielleicht noch nicht aber das
ist youtube und ich hatte vox
hochzuladen also viel spaß
die familie
der kammerchor versorgt werden und mich
jetzt da ich auch das gehört dann hab
ich in der sie die idee ich immer hier
leben noch ein ganz klein bisschen
reisen sehr selten
[Musik]
luca luka richtung vielleicht futter
glaube ich ins bett
vielleicht wir sind noch einkaufen oder
frisch chairman ed kann ja auch sein
[Musik]
dass die medien ganz sensiblen situation
aus
lucy du solltest dir das mal ganz kurz
eben anschauen
das usb stick machen mich in pc und
schaue video an lg entführer lustig
kommst mal eben ich habe nur usb stick
gefunden ja dann kommen danach wurde
jetzt ein stuhl setzt sich hier zu mir
das musst du dir unbedingt zu gemüte
führen falsch rum mensch auch juni kommt
der techniker weise nicht klar
[Musik]
schaller ich schon was machen wir jetzt